a connecticut family is planning to sue
the bridgeport police department saying
that it failed to properly investigate
the mysterious death of a young black
woman
twenty-three-year-old lauren smith feels
was her name she was found dead in her
home while reportedly on a date back in
december the white man whom she met on
the dating app bumble reported her dead
during their date now he is not facing
any charges so cbs news is not releasing
his name
yesterday though would have been
smithfield's 24th birthday family
friends and supporters marched in
bridgeport to celebrate her life demand
answers and justice smithfield's family
called detectives handling of the case
racially insensitive racially
insensitive and alleged that the college
student's civil rights were violated
lisa preston spoke with the family which
is calling for an outside
agency to now handle this investigation
elise good morning this is a very
troubling story very heartbreaking gail
good morning lauren smith fields should
be celebrating her 24th birthday this
week and said her family is fighting for
answers as to how the seemingly healthy
young woman reportedly died in her bed
family photos and memories are what
lauren smithfield's family is holding
onto as they wrestle with her unexpected
death the pain is so
unbearable chantelle field says she
drove to her daughter's apartment last
month after not hearing from her when i
got there
there was a note on the door saying if
you're looking for lauren call this
number the family says a detective told
them smithfields had been declared dead
about a day and a half earlier and no
one reached out to tell them he said
that she met some guy on bumble that
night and i'm like who's this guy what's
going on oh he sounds like a nice guy
don't worry about it according to an
incident report the date told police the
two allegedly spent the night drinking
eating and watching a movie at one point
he said smithfields went outside to meet
someone later she fell ill but the two
continued drinking smithfields fell
asleep and the date carried her to bed
where he went to sleep next to her hours
later around 6 30 in the morning he says
he woke up to smith fields not breathing
her nose bleeding he called 9-1-1 the
family says the detective also told them
to stop calling him for information they
were told he has since been removed from
the case
where all do you think the police
department misstepped in handling
lauren's death when you find a young
lady dead and there's a male involved is
immediately a person of interest and
they should immediately collected that
person's dna the incident report shows
police collected money in smithfield's
passport credit card and phone but the
family's attorney darnell crossland
stresses possible key evidence like
bloodied sheets and drinks was not
processed at the scene until two and a
half weeks later at the scene we find a
pill you find a condom with semen in it
in a statement to cbs news bridgeport
police acting chief rebecca garcia says
there are elements of misinformation
being reposted adding they will release
a final comprehensive report at the end
of their investigation people know that
black women black girls have been going
missing and haven't gotten any attention
and i think is at a boiling point we're
just asking for process that's it treat
these cases like you would treat any
others to lose lauren in this way how
does that make you feel
a part of my soul died
i would never be the same again i don't
even know how to even move from the next
day to next minute
i'm really
dead inside
the medical examiner's office tells cbs
news an autopsy report should be
complete in about a week the family has
paid out of pocket for an independent
autopsy as well elise i see why the
family has so many questions you know
black or white a man is found with your
daughter and just says uh she just fell
asleep and i woke up and she was dead
and the police say oh he's a nice guy
oh that makes no sense to me it's so
heartbreaking and and for them to not
know the mom said that she hadn't heard
from her daughter she goes to the door
and there's a note if you're looking for
lauren call this number and the number
was to the police department yeah
there's no effort to find the family or
track down the family according to the
family that they did not hear from the
police they also said that they waited
outside the house for five hours for
police to arrive and they never showed
up
it's devastating it is devastating i
hope they get the answers that they need
at least thank you so much thank you
very nice to meet you
glad to have you at this happy new year
thanks for having me